I don't know I hear there's like
something going on and I'm all dressed
up and ready to go on the sea is a red
carpet host Howie Mandel come straight
to me and he's holding in some big news
when I was America's Got Talent no
longer on Nick Cannon's not on the show
anymore the deal has been made and there
is a new host i will i will tell you
that later that night Tyra Banks
announces she's America's Got Talent new
host and how he tweets it her aight
aight i I'm howhow teach me how to smize
clean please sit down that's not
necessary but how he is hosting duties
of his own to worry about I am so proud
to be Canadian and a small part of this
I think we have to be a little louder
and let people know aside from this
country that this is our talents our
film and you're enjoying us I know
people have been talking about what is
it what is it called it's not like an
Oscar it's not like it what is that
screen television digital this will go
viral it's an SPD and it doesn't take
him long to single out Canada's favorite
clone you've got an STD last year didn't
you and look you're back you are back
for more this is our final season that
we're shooting right now overall you
know for complexity here it's really
exciting and I'm nominated for a movie
that I did with my buddies Tatiana
maslany wins best actress twice once for
her orphan black and the other for her
indie flick the other half thank you not
in attendance as a ba de la his film
it's only the end of the world racked up
a whopping six csa's or stds if thats
name is catching on but the night's top
honors go to Christopher Plummer who was
given a Lifetime Achievement Award I'm
old
dangerously old what does that mean to
you because I well it means a death is
just around the corner but I don't know
if there is another honor that would
make you people old more like a lifetime
ago yes I know the achievement is just
getting to where we are right now you
know a great quiz for plumber to honor
him in the way we did tonight was really
at a special special thing that's the
fun James and our backstage lounge after
just winning Best Actor for his film
race a biopic about Olympian Jesse Owens
80 years later on I bring this guy back
to life in a spin really the greatest
honor of my career to betray him so this
is different from that I've been shot
just because of this baby right here
right maybe a little bit a little bit
Dave Chappelle also drops by ER lounge
before presenting the icon award to just
for laughs where he first got his big
break in the early 90s I love montreal
this molest like changed my career I
couldn't pay my rent when I went and by
the time I came back I had television
deal offers and all that stuff like
literally was it was the first major
turning point congratulations you two
have fun and that's all sun yong li who
won best actor for his role on Kim's
convenience what a ride you phenomena
journey it's weird sort of political
time portrayal of an immigrant family on
a national broadcaster doing what all
families do which is try to make a life
for themselves it's so much more
important now than ever before now it's
just a whirlwind of talking being
interviewed by things like you know
celebrity hosts and stuff like that so
it's crazy